I felt a Republican issue years ago used
to be the environment even Nixon had a
Clean Air Act if you remember back in
history it was like a big deal and now I
feel like the Republicans have dropped
that they're kind of anti science are
you are you still considered a
Republican do you consider I'm I'm a
Republican I'm a traditional Republican
I'm a Reagan Republican I'm a Teddy
Roosevelt Republican are you involved
I'm a Lincoln Republican so that's the
kind of Republican am so if what the new
Republican Party does in the way they
veered off the republican principles is
their problem not mine I stayed true to
the republican principles which is did
you take care of your earth you take
care of your environment remember Ronald
Reagan created the Air Resources Board
in California they didn't Abra's us to
clean our air and how we were able to
reduce our greenhouse gases in
California a 25% which was supposed to
be by 2020 and we did it already in 2018
California was a leader oh we are the
leaders right in environmental laws we
are the leaders and at the same time we
are the leaders in the economic growth
because we have the greatest GDP of any
state in the United States and the fifth
largest GDP in the world so are you so
think about that this is wild because
most people don't know that that our GDP
is only behind you know the United
States China Japan and Germany then via
the fifth large as if we would be a
condiment with the fifth largest country
in the world to our GDP is twice as big
as Russia is so is your point that you
can be environmentalist and still do
well that's it's the point because so
many of the Republicans say we approach
jobs but we don't want to hurt the jobs
and we don't want to hear the economy so
therefore flat forget about the
environment it's absolute nonsense
because we have proven it here in
California that you can do both you can
take care of the environment and also
the economy at the same time I heard you
were starstruck when you met that little
girl yeah grater yeah I invited antastic
to our world summit in Vienna and this
girl's if one day said I'm not gonna go
to school and I'm gonna sit out in front
of the Capitol and I'm gonna protest
because they don't do enough in Sweden
right because Sweden is already doing a
lot for the environment right the
Swedish government
but she thought it was not enough so
she's sitting there and she's protesting
that going to school and created a lot
of attention and her whole spin was as
his weight you guys can [ __ ] around with
the environmental or you want but who is
he gonna affect my generation that's
right he's we're gonna inherit the world
and you have the responsibility to
handle with this world in better shape
than you inherited it so why she's
protesting it's got a lot of attention
and therefore now over said in the media
worldwide is now riding they have a new
kind of spin on writing about clean
environment and so that's it was she
really is a great great asset she's a
great communicator she gives feisty
speeches people so angry with her though
because it was one politician I was only
one side to this anger and this is the
right why because they're getting paid
for the coal companies and they're
getting paid by the oil companies and by
little car companies notice guys so they
get disturbed so they find problems with
you she's angry and all this kind of
stuff well of course she's angry that is
that is clear as it but she's brilliant
she's a very smart girl she's a
sweetheart of a girl and she's very
passionate about this cause